live here in Minneapolis Minnesota I
turned to my left I see a Super Bowl MVP
Super Bowl champion and an MVP of the
league he is the quarterback of the
Green Bay Packers Aaron Rodgers good to
see you sir you too buddy how are you
I'm doing well you are doing well I'm
doing well just so now that I have you
here in person on the show I have the
number of screws that were supposedly
put in your in your collarbone as
announced by the media and made number
is nine hundred and eighty-three of them
yeah is that is that inaccurate not a
Zilla hyah this when we heard that it
was just they were they were fluctuating
numbers all over the map yeah front yeah
there's a lot of misinformation fake
news out the hashtag it in hash tagging
so it's less it's less than that how's
lesson Atticus yeah okay more than ten
less than that number more than ten less
than that number is that does that break
hashtag breaking news I mean I can tweet
that out if you want now there's fire
emojis which we do whenever we're we're
worth one more I guess as we do when we
Huck take wheat hot take nice you know
yeah
I was hot taken yesterday what happened
I do hot take what I pulled a hamstring
doing it is bad well what a hot take a
hot take that if Brady throws three
interceptions in this game loses
Belichick will then quit the Patriots
tell the Giants he wants the job and
they'll fire Pat Shermer within less
than a week of having the job how hot
it's hot what do you think that's pretty
hot it's oh my god yeah that's clickbait
though isn't it well I thought you were
better than that you know I just lost my
mind you're back in that I am better I
just I don't want to do that same
science a team that doesn't have an
actual head coach at this point hmm
they're brows
well the Browns have a head coach coach
they were all day it's all filled it's
all filled so I had to choose somebody
is it no field yeah they are
where's well the Colts haven't I mean
coach habits but not yeah you'd think
it's one of those two budda bill says
hey I'm out of here I'm out of here I
know well they're gonna choose McDaniels
or Patricia over bill this is a hot take
oh there we go all right
wrong you're not wrong just so he would
Bogart the job of one of his assistants
now that would be great and then would
would he hire one of them yeah I like
this
fire emoji has it actually here's what
we should do
Aaron you should take one view point
I'll take the other we'll split screen
it and then we'll start having an
argument I'm saying that if he takes
Detroit Patricia doesn't get hired
mm-hmm doesn't he take the job okay and
Josh mm might hmm okay what makes you
think that
not just sue I'm gonna take that side I
think you're wrong you don't know what
you're talking about and LeBron sucks we
should have a show on ESPN we just you
know it's exactly what I should do is
just basically pitch it right now
i Rodgers here on the Rich Eisen show
okay so what do you think of this
matchup sir what do you think of this
matchup I think that people usually in a
Super Bowl say two weeks for Bill
Belichick and Josh McDaniels is too long
I think
people need to say that about the other
side as well for Doug and his staff and
Jim Schwartz because what they did last
week last game they played in
championship was impressive so worth 38
on a great defense and gave up seven so
I like I like their chances more than
probably a lot of people though that you
know there's a lot of allegedly people
that bet on this sport I saw some about
a lot of money going in on on Philly
mm-hmm
still you know with what the Patriots
have done 20 to 3 last year you know
it's it's tough to think they won't be
ready to play and come out on top so you
know I watch sports TV obviously in a
different manner because I do it for a
living when you watch Tom Brady when you
watch him play a football game knowing
what he's doing reading defense is
knowing what he's doing
by trying to take care of business when
somebody schemes their way to them what
do you think when you're watching Tom
Brady play the game well I'm impressed
you know he's done it for so long it's
just a high level what I love to see now
is and what I like you know talking him
about is his movement you know I like
what he's he's kind of ad and the that
to his game where he's been moving in
the pocket more so moving to throw but
you've seen him you know in the past I
watched every every snap he took in 2007
he a phenomenal year that year I was a
backup and I was amazed at his subtle
pocket movements he could just move
slightly and creative throwing Lane now
he seems to be more back and up and then
out to throw and even last year in a
Super Bowl you know he ran for a couple
first downs that's what's impressive to
me is he's he's have all been adapting
you know he's obviously takes care of
himself really well but now he's kind of
adding that pocket movement where he's
getting up and out which was been great
Darron Rogers here on the Rich Eisen
show care of Marriott which we'll get to
in a minute what do you mean you watched
every one of his snaps in 2007 when I
was encouraged by my quarterback coach
to to watch them the best guys I always
thought he was the best he threw for
like 50 touchdowns a year so I said what
a better filmer watch than that you know
he think I was struck by was majority of
his completions involved some sort of
eye control or head movement very rarely
was he picking it sticking in eyes to a
certain style or than a normal time it
was he's great with his eye discipline
and I just loved his subtle pocket
movement so you know to watch for of
every day and then to watch guys like
like Tommy you know you got to
incorporate that stuff in your game hmm
who would you quarterback coach at the
time Tom Clements Tom Clements yeah okay
and so now was Peterson there at any
point in to him when you first got Doug
yeah was he no I actually took his
locker and
he was on the way out I was on the way
yeah took his long tired yeah
but the first year round I get a message
that Doug Peterson wants somebody down
there his charity event in Louisiana and
Doug could not have been nicer during
about the transition about everything
that involved being a you know
quarterback in Green Bay and playing
with bread and expectations and just
he's an overall great guy and I'm really
happy for him you know the saying it
couldn't happen to a better guy it's
thrown around sometimes sure Doug is
really that guy that's great happy for
that's great to hear
Aaron Rodgers see what are you doing
with Marriott I'm out here hanging out
with those great folks as part of their
their loyalty program Marriott Rewards
an SPG they put on these VIP experiences
and I got part of that I don't know how
VIP I am in Minnesota we're doing a cool
intimate thing tomorrow night I'm
hosting a party for 12 they brought out
12 of their top members and guests and a
guest and so we're having a nice little
intimate night tomorrow night cue a
hangout pictures selfies or whatever the
heck they want but you know Mira does
some really awesome things in this room
where they create these VIP packages for
their folks whether it's throwing out
the first pitch at the World Series
which has happened or whether it's you
know getting to meet to your favorite
hero in sports or somebody you respect
maybe not hero but some of you respect
in sports or entertainment they put the
others great packages for the members
and it's fun to be a part of it with
them there there's some great people
Aaron Rodgers here on the show before
right before you leave I'd like to play
a game that we've created here called
Stark bench cut similar to that you know
blank marry kill game that we always
used to play as kids okay
we as kids Wow or as collegiate adults
or last week and we call it Stark bench
cut so you can have to start somebody
benched somebody and cut somebody will
have a Game of Thrones theme to it yes
Vince it's gonna be quiet or cut all
right what's the first one Chris
Brockman what a first one is your
favorite game of Thrones character okay
to give him the three Khaleesi Jon Snow
Jorah Mormont mmm get our Sam Scott got
the star got bench one and calm starting
Khaleesi mother of dragons breaker of
chains I'm benching Jorah and I'm
cutting John's cottony rivalry Johnny's
trying to it's cutthroat because we also
knew him one of the many times you have
conversations you're a big Jorah fan I
am I am and now that he's got the he's
back racing you out do you know is he
okay so Jon Snow's out and Jon's out he
could be in another one right the
nastiest MFR on Game of Thrones you have
to start one you have to bench one and
cut Ramsay Bolton Walder Frey Joffrey
fits nastiest I mean you got to start
Ramsay he's the worst
I mean he is a woked mmm right he's the
worst of all types of all-time
I'm gonna bench Joffrey cuz he's close
you know he the stuff that he did any
sons has put up with all this crap from
the men in her life success man exactly
baseball to Frey he's up there but his
death was okay was excited so you caught
him he's out he's out okay well which he
actually was in fact cut literally from
all that okay and then we'll just do one
more it's not it's not we did this one
with you yes Jeff Garlin had a great
time at your expense
yes favorite movie okay the three
choices are Shawshank Redemption
the fugitive you've got mail hmm start
bench cut I'm starting the fugitive I
mean Tommy Lee and Harrison Ford Fanta
it's the best right I'm gonna bench
shank phenomenal movie as well and I'm
cutting you've got mail
well if you've got long you've got mail
not even the best Tom Hanks meg Ryan
movie Seattle that was like a phone call
on a radio show but you've got dial-up
you've got dial-up email yeah come on
now you guys you guys are wrong all
right at Aaron Rodgers 12 on Twitter and
Instagram and Instagram is yeah oh
you're on the I ejected on the ground
okay live story yesterday with Spieth
Golf in Scottsdale Wow okay missed that
we're just saying with the comment thing
yet see you're just getting started okay
at Aaron Rodgers 12 care of Marriott and
I think I'm gonna see you with that
event done on Friday night great to have
you that's Aaron Rodgers here the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience